est-ce que 2020 c'était la pire and
lorsqu'on a entendu toute l'année nick
nolte chaire train d'y penser pour le
tournage
anecdote au moment du nouvel an 2020
donc avec mes potes on disait pas genre
bonnes années 2020 on disait joyeux 20
20 ça faisait trop déranger je voyais
par 20 voix
je reprends est-ce que du coup c'est la
pire année
non parce que c'est ce qu'on a entendu
dès le début il faut que j'arrête de
rigoler parce que je parlais de trucs un
peu triste qu'ils sont arrivés dès le
début on n'arrêtait pas de se dire ok
2020 ça sent la merde avec les feux en
australie le fait qu on flirte avec la
troisième guerre mondiale
et puis je passe bien entendu parler le
corps d'un virus sévit un truc ça n'a
pas arrêté et c'est allé très loin ce
truc de piran et ça allait tellement
loin que le time time magazine l'a
déclarée comme pire année du monde donc
tout le monde semble être d'accord là
dessus et parfois j'ai même l'impression
que si on a passé une année 2020 plutôt
correct eh ben on est la pire des
enflures alors est-ce que 2020 c'est
vraiment la pire année
évidemment non et on le sait tous
n'importe qui de sensé c'est qu'à
l'échelle de l'humanité 2020 c'est pas
la pire année
mais pour beaucoup d'entre nous qui
sommes trentenaire vingtenaires
quarantenaire nés en france
bah c'est l'une des pires années qu'on
ait vécu effectivement mais à quelques
années qui permettent de prendre
conscience quand même que la nôtre
c'était relativement ok je n'aime pas
parler de 39-45 et des actes de barbarie
que l'humanité a connu à ce moment là je
vais essayer de vous parler d'année qui
auquel on pense peut-être un petit peu
moins par exemple 1919 donc l'europe est
détruite
on est à la sortie de la première
mondiale traité de versailles donc on
est en train de se répartir des morceaux
de terre qui sont l'économie allemande
va bien serrer la vis à l'allemagne ce
qui va préparer la suite donc belle
erreur et rajoutez à ça la grippe
espagnole qui fait plus de morts que la
première guerre mondiale
et on vient de sortir de la guerre belle
année de merde en 1968 en france cette
année avec énormément de d'émeutes de
violence wallace a renoncé parce qu'on
est français mais c'était le cas partout
dans le monde en amérique du nord genre
au canada ils ont même appelé ça le
lundi de la matraque en italie au japon
et aussi l'assassinât de martin
et aussi l'assassinât de robert kennedy
qui était le frère de john kennedy qui
était en pleine campagne présidentielle
et j'allais pas vous laisser sans une
petite grippe évidemment la grippe de
hong kong 1 million de morts anne est
complexe mais ça c'est l'histoire
récente
mais les gars ya 65 millions d'années la
terre et ses primes et héroïque de patar
pleine face ok genre les scientifiques
parlent d'une puissance de 10 milliards
10 milliard de bombes atomiques ou 100
trillions de tonnes de tnt
mon cerveau n'est pas capable de procès
ces informations et en plus c'est tombé
sur une zone avec énormément de soufre
donc et du soufre qui s'est dégagé dans
l'atmosphère et donc 80% des espèces
vivantes
à ce moment là sur terre n'ont pas
survécu grosse année merde à l'année où
il ya cette météorite année merde je
triche un peu parce qu'on n'était pas
encore là les l'humanité mais vous avez
compris l'idée est ensuite il ya
évidemment une année qui revient souvent
quand on fait des recherches sur la pire
année au monde c'est 536 après
jésus-christ en gros éruption volcanique
de bâtard qui se produit en islande
nuages qui se propagent sur l'hémisphère
nord
ça bloque les rayons du soleil plus de
soleil pendant genre 18 mois 18 mois ok
donc baisse de température de quelques
degrés 2,5 degrés max apparemment mais
c'est assez pour que il neige en plein
été au mois d'août en chimie est donc
évidemment problème de récolte grosse
famine dans le monde voit la famille
bien violente quoi beaucoup de morts
beaucoup nord année de merde année de
merde et c'est le début de l'enfer en
fait parce qu'à une autre éruption
volcanique qui se produit
quatre ans plus tard évidemment en
quatre ans les gens s'en sont pas remis
en bref de nouveaux famine et ses
températures qui baissent organismes
affaiblis et là qu'est ce qui se passe
peste bubonique ça tu globalement la
moitié de la population de l'empiré
romain d'orient
voilà donc là c'est même plus une année
de merde c'est une période de merde
j'aurais pu vous parler de la grande
famine de traits 115 trade 117 qui tue 5
à 10% de la population européenne est ce
que je le fais non non on a compris le
en avril ib nous quand on pense à tout
ça moi je me dis que le fait que cette
année c'est censé être la pire mason au
monde quand même qu'on a
coup de chance quoi on le savait mais je
me dis si c'est ça nos événements qui
sont bouleversants honnêtement ça va
évidemment c'est dur on vit tous plus ou
moins bien et on a tous des événements
extérieurs qui nous sont tombées dessus
quoi ça peut être la perte d'un emploi
ou bien plus dure la perte d'un proche
mais malgré ça la vérité c'est que ça
pourrait être toujours pire parce que
cette année 2020 on sait pas à quel
point elle aurait pu être plus
dramatique
le virus aurait pu être beaucoup plus
violent par exemple et de la même
manière on est peut-être passé à côté
d'événements dramatiques en termes de
terrorisme en termes de guerre en termes
d' assassinat on saura jamais et puis en
vrai sans parler de ce qui aurait pu
arriver de pire
il ya plein de bonnes choses qui sont
arrivées en 2020 il ya plein de bonnes
choses dans ce coup d'arrêt en fait
qu'on s'est pris pour beaucoup le fait
d'être forcé de s'arrêter par quelque
chose qui était extérieur à nous ça nous
a incités à faire des choses qu'on ne
prenait jamais le temps de faire je
pense que c'est pour ça qu'il est des
tendances un peu chelou pendant
confinement genre par exemple faire son
pain maison ils perdent chaude ou cette
tendance doute asseoir et en fait quand
on y réfléchit à ça a du sens c'est une
superbe façon de se reconnecter à ce
qu'on consomme à ce qu'on mange
c'est une activité manuelle aussi qui
nous met en lien avec la terre en fait
d'une certaine façon en fait il ya tout
un tas de choses positives
derrière ce truc de faire son pain un
autre élément positif c'était de se
rendre compte à quel point certaines
choses que l'on prenait pour acquises ne
l'était pas il ya plein de scènes qui
nous semblait anodine et jeu qui nous
choque aujourd'hui vous avez tous fait
l'expérience en regardant un film ou des
photos et on voit plein de gens
rassemblés et c'est sans masque ça fait
un petit truc chelou quoi avant ça me
saoule et quand on parlait trop près en
boîte de nuit
maintenant je rêve qu'on postillonne
dessus au delà de tout ça est ce que ça
a vraiment un sens de parler de meilleur
ou de piran est d'abord de par la place
de la souffrance vous en avait parlé
dans ma vidéo sur les trente ans la
souffrance est intrinsèque à la vie
est-ce que ça a du sens de dire qu'une
année elle est bien ou pas bien en
fonction de la quantité de souffrances
qu'elle nous apporte
est-ce qu'on est ok pour dire que les
événements extérieurs à nous font que
notre vie est meilleur ou moins
je suis pas sûr et dans ce cas-là
définir une pire ou une meilleure année
à l'échelle de l'humanité a très peu de
sens et si on va plus loin est ce que ça
a du sens de juger une période aussi
longue c'est déjà difficile de juger une
semaine alors une année vraiment moi je
veux dire mon expérience perso cette
année c'était l'une des plus dures si ce
n'est la plus dures années de ma vie
vous savez si vous me suivez sur les
réseaux si vous ratez aucune vidéo de ma
chaîne voilà vous le savez je vous en ai
parlé déjà c'était horrible ça l'est
toujours ça change de forme voilà ça
évolue et pourtant cette année il ya
aussi un matin je me suis levé et je me
suis dit aujourd'hui
j'emménage avec la femme que j'aime
c'était cette année aussi et c'était un
moment incroyable
c'était fou de vivre ça et j'en ai plein
en fait des moments d'amour comme ça
incroyable est ce que est ce que je dois
jeter ces moments là est ce que parce
que j'ai vécu des moments moins bien ces
moments là au moins deux sens
je pense pas je pense pas c'est très
difficile de juger une période aussi
longue
parce qu il se passe plein de choses
différentes est-ce que ce qui compte
finalement ce n'était pas le moment
l'instant quand on juge une période
aussi longue on tue l'instant l'instant
n'existe plus et pas les instants qu'on
juge on va pas juger une somme
d'instance pas possible donc on juge
plutôt des acquis des pertes d'une forme
de bilan comptable mais c'est difficile
de juger ce qu'on vit surtout qu'ils
étaient bière en plus et des biais
cognitifs qui font que se souvient
peut-être plus de certaines choses
négatives que positives
donc on n'est pas honnête dans le
jugement je suis totalement en
improvisation j'ai quitté mon script
voilà est-ce que ça a du sens de juger
une année sur sa globalité pour - nom
est telle que j'ai vécu mon année c'est
même impossible
alors si je reprends le titre est ce que
2020 c'était la pire année
c'était une année extrêmement difficile
mais ce serait se voiler la face de dire
que c'était la pire année est ce que nos
problèmes vont s'arrêter brutalement en
non ce qui peut commencer par contre
c'est cultiver notre gratitude par
rapport au fait qu'on sait pas pris
impute un astéroïde en pleine face merci
de m'avoir suivi sur cette année 2020
c'est une année en termes perso
évidemment vous accomp restée un
extrêmement particulière mais même en
terme entre guillemets pro faire sur ma
chaîne youtube et tout voilà il ya eu
beaucoup de changements éditorialement
c'est une année où j'ai l'impression
d'avoir évolué un petit peu la ligne
édito de la chaîne je peux faire des
billets d'humeur comme des vidéos plus
travailler c'est aussi une année où j'ai
commencé les live sur twitter et on a
vécu de supers moments sur twitch
c'était vraiment trop cool et plein de
trucs gens mais ça va continuer en 2021
d'ailleurs au passage ce soir donc
dimanche 27 et sur twitch avec hugo et
atom et on va parler de tout net on va
décrypter et honnête je vous faire
gagner des steelbook 4k et deborah il y
en aura quatre ans tout à gagner avec
des quiz et tout ça va être galerie que
c'est ce soir 19h30 fin de la parenthèse
bref voilà en terme de vidéo j'ai
l'intention d'avoir une vraie liberté
quoi j'ai l'impression de pouvoir vous
faire un appartement de tour quand tout
sera sera terminé quand je serai
vraiment bien installée et tout comme je
peux vous faire une vidéo sur la
phénoménologie comme je peux vous faire
une vidéo sur un réacteur à l'est comme
je faisais avec les honneurs sur
internet par exemple
donc voilà ça c'est hyper plaisant et je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
depuis six semaines
il ya une vidéo par semaine c'est cool
que j'ai cette liberté éditoriale
d'ailleurs pour pouvoir faire une vidéo
par semaine parce que voilà c'est les
sujets sont différents j'ai des vidéos
qui prennent plus de temps que d'autres
et si je le fais rêver au par semaine
il faut que je puisse mettre une vidéo
légère de temps en temps et des vidéos
poussée de temps en temps et voilà que
je joue avec tout ça et vous me
permettez de jouer tout ça donc ces gens
mais en fait c'est trop bien là pour
être très honnête je risque de faire une
pause d'une semaine ou deux histoire de
seins peux m'organiser pour pouvoir
tenir le plus longtemps possible
ce truc d'une vidéo par semaine et c'est
parce que je l'aï un peu commencé comme
ça je me suis fait un peu prendre de
cours à moi même et là j'ai envie de
le planifier je pense que ça peut
vraiment faire du bien à ma chaîne pour
voilà et j'espère que vous me suivre et
là dedans et je voulais déjà dit je vous
dis tout le temps mais merci quoi merci
voilà merci merci d'être là quoi voilà
je leur dis que je le redis mais voilà
dès que j'ai l'occasion de le dire je
dis ça me fait plaisir de le dire là je
le dis voilà par contre truc que j'ai
oublié de dire dans la vidéo c'est que
le t-shirt que je porte
il dit reste à peu près 16 jours pour le
précommander t-shirt ou souhaitent
et voilà et apprécié c'est ce jour là
ils seront plus disponibles et j'en
profite pour vous remercier à tous ceux
qui ont déjà passé la précommande ça m'a
beaucoup touché ça me fait plaisir
donc voilà je suis content que ce soit
un tee shirt ou un chouette qui vous
plaisent et dernière chose je voulais
faire une vidéo avant le 31 décembre
pour vous rappeler que c'est le meilleur
moment pour se créer une habitude je
vous remets ma vidéo sur les habitudes
je voulais mais là et je vous mets en
descriptions et c'est parce que c'est un
point d'ancrage important le 1er janvier
c'est un point d'ancrage mine de rien
voilà c'est une nouvelle année etc et
l'ancrage on aime bien pour la technique
de la chaîne que je vous avais expliqué
dans cette vidéo là donc je voulais vous
faire une vidéo là dessus je n'ai pas
fait mais je pense que je vais vous
envoyer une newsletter pour vous parler
de moi ce que je vais faire ce que je
veux c'est mettre en place et vous
donner envie peut-être te voilà vous
créez des défis aussi je vous mets un
lien dans la description pour s'inscrire
à la newsletter
mais de toute façon je vous en
reparlerai à mon avis en janvier ça fera
peut être l'objet d'une vidéo parce que
il faut que je parle parce que si je me
crée des défis pour l'année 2000 21 j'ai
envie de vous en parler en vidéo parce
que comme ça ça ne mettra un peu au pied
du mur si j'arrive pas à les faire voilà
c'est tout c'est tout ça à peu près tous
merci merci encore
très belles fêtes de fin d'année à tout
le monde un message particulier à celles
et ceux qui sont seuls
un message particulier à celles et ceux
qui ont perdu quelqu'un cette année un
message particulier aussi à celles et
ceux voilà qui se sont retrouvées sans
emploi qui sont dans l'incertitude qui
sont dans les doutes qui sont dans la
peur ça fera l'objet d'une vidéo mais
c'est un truc important à se rappeler
c'est que tout n'est qu'un permanence
tout mais toujours qu'un permanence et
même votre situation de merde que vous
êtes en train de vivre actuellement elle
va s'arrêter un moment et ça est bien
vrai plus que jamais love peace
approchant qu'on me dise oui à des gens
qui regardent cette vidéo et qui
concernait 2020 c'était vraiment leur
pire année sont sûrs à 1000% que c'était
leur pire année ever est bien dans ce
cas là félicitations c'est une
excellente nouvelle parce qu'elle est
passée donc il reste que du kif donc
tout le reste ça va easy